the release of the Disney Plus series a
Mandalorian has brought with it one of
the most adorable creatures in the
entire Star Wars Canon we are of course
talking about baby Yoda whose tiny green
frame and big floppy ears have captured
the hearts of fans around the world stop
touching things there are still plenty
of questions surrounding baby Yoda and
Lucasfilm is keeping quiet for now which
obviously has only driven Star Wars fans
into more of a frenzy just what is the
trial significance to the greatest Star
Wars universe
what is its connection with the Yoda we
know and love and how powerful is this
child
well those questions might remain a
mystery for now but in a recent
interview with Esquire two-time Star
Wars director JJ Abrams offered up a few
suggestions as to why the character
exists in the first place
Abrams explained Star Wars is ever
expanding and the ability to choose a
character like Yoda and say what if we
created a baby Yoda the reason these
things are reasonable to people is
because it's not just nostalgia it's
taken something that is meaningful a
story that has deep roots and potency
and resonates with a human heart a
beating heart Abrams went on to suggest
that baby Yodas appeal comes from far
more than the creatures cuteness he said
these are the kind of things that's when
they hit it's not just cute but it
implies a story it sparks the
imagination all these things are about
the possibility potential and that's the
very heart of what Star Wars this but
the universe like star wars that has
grown so dramatically from the release
of the first film there's always going
to be room for more more heroes more
villains more lightsaber battles more
evil dictatorships and of course more
cuteness Abrams is clearly in favor of
expanding the Star Wars universe as much
as possible
and the introduction of another of Yoda
species is just one way of doing that
Abrams told Esquire I think that the fun
of telling stories and the galaxy is
that you get to take things that are
familiar and you get to adjust them
augment them comment on them continue
them it's a world that is looking to be
expanded Abrams also pointed out that
the Star Wars galaxy has always been
bigger than it actually seemed he said
the original movie said the most
remarkable thing in reference
the Clone Wars and the Empire and the
Senate and the old Wars and never
showing any of these things but he
always felt that was a peripheral life
and history and world beyond what you
were seeing at Abrams has kept quiet on
whether or not baby Yoda story can have
an impact on the rise of Skywalker or
whether the character itself could even
appear but regardless of whether or not
the child shows up in the final chapter
of the Skywalker saga one question
remains could baby yoda help establish
the foundation for a new era of Star
Wars films George Lucas purposefully
left he owed his origins a mystery to
Star Wars fans making him the only
creature in the known galaxies whose
species is not explicitly named we know
he isn't the only one of his kind
because a female of the species Master
Udall appeared in the Phantom Menace but
little else is known about Yoda and his
origins having baby Yoda feature in
upcoming Star Wars films to potentially
clear up a few mysteries about the tiny
green Jedi Master from his species
origin so their apparent natural
strength with the force it would also
link the new era of Star Wars to the old
and try the small screen universe to the
silver one and fortunately Abrams hasn't
offered up any theories as to how much
information the Mandalorian might reveal
about Yoda species but there's still a
few episodes left of the show to come
and who knows how much deeper the Star
Wars galaxy might get check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Star Wars are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the pal so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]